I'm not against it even though it it do
scare me cardi B Taylor Swift and more
stars are speaking out amid the George
Floyd riots Taylor Swift called out
president Donald Trump for threatening
violence against the protesters tweeting
in part after stoking the fires of white
supremacy and racism your entire
presidency we will vote you out in
November the 30 year old singers
statement on social media was in
response to the president's tweet to
those protesting in Minneapolis
Minnesota following the fatal arrest of
George Floyd the 45th president called
rioters of George's death thugs on
Twitter and claimed that their actions
are dishonouring the memory of George
adding quote when the looting starts the
shooting starts but many are now citing
this quote from Martin Luther King jr.
to help explain what's going on
Orion is the language of the unheard the
current protests come after decades upon
decades of similar instances that have
resulted in what feels like deja vu for
Americans I don't want anybody to get
hurt but it's just it's really
frustrating you want to know why because
police brutality been going on even even
way before I was born
these hashtags keep freaking repeating
themselves I've been doing police
brutality videos ever since my tape and
stuff today
so many are hurt angry and broken
because of the feeling that black lives
are devalued in the US where the riots I
put that on TV a number of celebrities
are speaking out about the current
injustice of Floyd's death including
Miguel Kelly Rowland Kim Kardashian and
Tracee Ellis Ross who shared this video
I'm a young black man
doing all that I can
eateat previously reported Floyd was a
46 year old black man who died on May
25th after he was arrested for suspicion
of forgery outside of a deli the video
of the arrest shows him on the ground
repeatedly telling the white police
officer identified as Derrick Chauvin
who was kneeling on his neck that he
couldn't breathe Floyd was later
pronounced dead on Friday Minneapolis
Public Safety Commissioner John
Harrington announced that Chauvin now an
ex-police officer had been arrested in
relation to Floyd's death
[Music]
[Applause]